we actually aren't looking for a middle
ground with capitalism we're not looking
for a lighter gentler oppression
exploitation racism we are seeking
revolution my name is Liberty I'm
studying psychology at UCLA I'm 20 years
old I'm Shawn I'm 24 years old and I'm
in the Socialist Party my name's Mimi
2016 I was the Socialist Party's
presidential candidate I'm shy and I'm
with the Socialist Party and I'm 28
my name is Jack I'm 19 I go to Community
College my name is Richard 19 I go to
Cal State Long Beach as a chemistry
major with a music minor I get my
socialist on the left and my capitalist
on the right humans are inherently
selfish selfishness is sort of one word
for it
but looking out for yourself your own
survival in your own gain and of course
that includes the gain of those you love
is one of the main motivators of people
a really good way that we could figure
out human nature is by comparing it to
animal nature and stuff like that and
you see you know animals doing whatever
they can to survive it's just culture
that has changed us but I believe at its
core that yes humans just like any other
animal are I selfish I work with
children and my experience of working
with people who haven't been
acculturated or I've been in into this
idea that they need to be selfish all
the time are generally not every
organism has to have a sense of like
getting resources for itself Android
survive but that's a much different than
being selfish I think I mean I think
even if you look at if you spend any
time in a social democracy you know
let's say you go to Norway and you spend
time there where the people see the
collective good as tied into their own
personal well-being you know I think we
have so many examples like that
societies working collectively toward a
greater good
the thing about the Nordic countries in
my opinion is well since there's very
very ethnically homogeneous they all
have very very similar culture it's not
an accurate representation of you know
what humans inherently are because I
believe that culture can mask human
nature so you think that diversity would
work against working in harmony toward a
collective good in diversity we have
different ideas of what good is I think
competition brings out the best in
people especially when you know we're
competing for something like let's try
to create this compound that could help
you know the masses in some kind of
health relation form you have all these
research labs trying to figure out
what's the most efficient way to figure
out this process what's the most
efficient way to do this I think we need
more that sort of sense of competition
especially in the sciences and whatnot
you know we frequently hear about the
evils of monopolies it's because you
know with when you control an entire
market why even bother being better
anything you've got no competition
you've got nothing to strive for and no
one can choose anything else I agree
with you both on the examples that you
gave but the thing that I'm kind of
struggling with I mean if we're talking
about
efficiency quality then yeah I think it
brings out the best in people but then
again it tends to bring about greed you
all do us such a great service it's it's
a trip to me because as you're likely
aware that there's this growing support
for socialism an economic system that
places people over profit that
you're willing to continue to throughout
the same talking points that have failed
people so miserably again it's it's a
benefit to us and I guess we should say
thank you nice if you care about
something if you're passionate about
something you don't need the threat of
someone doing it better than you to do
the best that you can do ask any
creative competition leads less to
excellence and more towards doing
whatever you can to edge past the other
person today everyone has the
opportunity for success alright if we're
talking about the United States and
we're talking about financial success
then yes I would believe so if we're
talking about the world it doesn't
necessarily have to mean financial
well-being or like stability I think
that it really just means how you're
happy and how you're okay with yourself
and you know you make a goal and you
pursue your goal and if you have a large
exactly what I was thinking I find that
there are so many resources out there
that you can enact on it's just there's
some people who just don't do anything
about it
my first thought here with this question
is you got to be [ __ ] kidding me you
know so many people in this country
whose solely because they exist they're
under threat whether it's through you
know the police they're just trying to
survive so everyone's very different
again everyone has different
opportunities to what they can even
consider success in in the u.s. though
there are a lot of opportunities for
most people though of course you can't
say all and there are always those who
are extremely unfortunate and should be
helped I'm sure every one of us is sat
in a restaurant before
Starbucks those people work their asses
off any of these low income jobs are not
easy and they they work for pennies if
something goes wrong with their car
they're done you know if they have a
health problem they're done you're
talking about financial success though
success is extremely relative and can be
defined in many different ways in a
capitalist society those in financials
is the most important thing no I I've
worked in the food industry for a number
of years and I could not say that any
one of my companions was ever happy to
be doing that and if they're going the
stools on top of that you know so
they're working full-time and on top of
that they're going to school and they're
paying school I would consider that
successful if you can go to school and
you can maintain your GPA you can also
be working a part-time job and somehow
afford in your school yeah you're doing
well in life society should help the
underprivileged
that sort of saying if you give a man a
fish etc it holds true and also who
should do the helping and how is very
important not all acts of service are
equally beneficial i would agree to that
i myself you know i'm sorry to use a
personal anyt anecdote here but i've
personally dealt with the fact that oh
giving someone this much aid they become
they become lazy
my father is an alcoholic so we since
due to an injury in his leg he gets ssi
and what's and what ends up happening is
he receives enough ssi to the point
where he's not he's not motivated to do
anything else beyond just going home
drinking a beer or something like that
and i think yes people should help
people especially if they're under under
privileged or they need the resources to
push them put to what end that's that's
the fine line but your personal anecdote
only only covers the small demographic
of the of the alcoholic most of people
that that brought up has been
specifically about people who are
particularly poor when most of the
country is middle lower middle class and
up that's lots actually that's not a
fact that you would focus on this in a
[ __ ] in a city one that gives more than
half of its budget to the police in a
country that just passed the military
bill a spending bill that's almost one
trillion dollars that money goes to
defense contractors government paying
for things is not capitalism but we're
in a capitalist system where the
government pays huge amounts of money
the military yeah those things how about
instead of spending the money on the
military how about putting those back
into basic means health care education
housing i agree we don't weren't taking
our taxpayer dollars and funneling it
into their paying for things that the
military explicitly says that they don't
mean
that's not capitalism is about prices
and transparency and and choices we
don't even take some money and biases
actually decide Louis I'm working that
is not what you call capitalism but when
I come here saying I'm gonna capitalist
I'm not saying I'm in favor of that
profit and ethics are opposing motives
so I think it's core to profit you have
to exploit and again there is nothing
ethical about exploitation yeah I mean I
can't think it I I'm really having
trouble thinking of a situation where
someone could profit off of something
with that exploitation being the mix and
I just I'm running out of ideas if
you're running a business and you know
you're you're the one up top you would
obviously walk away with more money if
you pay your employees a little bit less
I think that profit and ethics can be
intertwined when seen with the corporate
social responsibility module when they
treat their employees better they give
them more benefits they raise their
wages and in turn it motivates the
workers to work harder and treating your
employees better than [ __ ] is not
necessarily as a car like raising the
quality it does not mean that you've
raised it to a sufficient standard of
treatment because if you're paying
someone less than a living wage that is
unethical all I'm saying is it is to
some degree more ethical and can be seen
as more ethical to be beating
competition by raising the wages of your
employees and giving them better
benefits also one must be paid slightly
less than they are making an worth for a
company for it to be worth it to hire
them at all if you can't pay your
employee the minimum amount of money
that they need in order to live you have
no business being in business and I
think also there's a tendency from the
conservative side to skew away from sort
objective fact I mentioned the MIT
living wage calculator right yes that's
a scientific model that 2925 so as a
company if you can't afford to pay your
employee a living wage that's just the
minimum that they need in order to live
right get the [ __ ] out of business why
are we even talking to you when you have
all the facts and we don't know anything
I don't know hardly worth my time well
we were sure it's hard to really lean
towards one side or the other if
everyone is just sort of stating all
these coherent biases and not accepting
any sort of thing from any other
particular side which is why I'm sort of
just I'm trying to understand your side
and I'm trying to understand really my
side of it and again going back to sort
of that mutual understanding of what can
we do next that sort of mutual
understanding needs to be there if if
we're gonna ever continue to see what's
best for for the u.s. I think one reason
why you know you often see like folks on
the left the socialist communist
anarchists or etc they're so passionate
and there's anger you know seeing the
suffering and the oppression and the
exploitation the racism etc you're sort
of feel this urgency you know like we're
constantly under sort of this
self-criticism and self-reflection about
like well how do you package what can be
complex ideas into ways that are very
palatable and I think if there's a
failure on the left that would be one of
them I wish that rather than having an
agenda that we try to prove and we see
ourselves as winning by convincing the
opponent I wish that we could consider
winning as finding the middle ground and
finding where we're similar and finding
the truth I think if you're in the
pursuit of truth then you've won
contrary to convincing other people that
you're right you know despite that we
definitely disagree on pretty much
everything it's good to know that the
real common ground here is we is like
Millennials and Gen Z and stuff we're
actually we're actually like talking
about this like whether we were able to
convince the other side of anything or
not at least we give a [ __ ] about it you
know this is stuff that we need to talk
about this is stuff that we need to be
aware of especially going our leaders so
down all right hey guys thanks for
watching that episode of middle ground
here at Jubilee we believe in this idea
of radical empathy and that is what
middle ground is all about so we want to
hear your thoughts on this topic and
this discussion so let us know in the
comments below please click here to
subscribe and watch more of our videos
and remember to live greater